all right first game
and there it is and aa175 what can you
tell me about him
so i can i can give you a pretty honest
scouting report canadian talent you know
one of the god damn best to ever do it
uh young kid he's uh he's you know for
for canada
standards you know we don't produce many
talents but uh for his age he's
definitely he's definitely doing pretty
well he's got the fm title
young kid 12 13 years old and he's a
regular around not only this channel but
a lot of channels he's got a lot of
experience
just sort of like being active on twitch
playing sub battles and tournaments for
you know
whatever streams fantastic i respect
that but 186
well he is a french player i'm gonna
reveal a secret and he's
a very experienced blitz flight good
positional player um
also young kid but good at positional
chess
which is kind of rare nowadays and we
gotta gruenfeld's
and one thing iman that i am going to
get mad about
is is time like my i can remain level
headed but when it comes to time
pressure oh and e5 that is a fashion
blind knight takes d5e4 i get so worked
up about people just
you sometimes have to move fast
regardless of whether you know how to do
regards to whether you know what to do
and and that just like takes me off
so i warn you i will be doing some
shouting in time for you
oh this is good then this is this was a
call that needed to happen
we'll be very in line with that i've
seen this line recently actually it's
very very uh
interesting and i don't like that our
guy has already spent a minute
so the great thing is that now that
you're on the call with me
it's a very different type of commentary
now i can just pretend that i knew that
this was theory
if we were commentating separately i
would be like what the hell is this
what is this no clue what's going on but
but now i can be like oh yeah you know
theory i definitely knew that of course
of course yeah well you know that story
with bobby fischer when he was like
analyzing a game with his teammates
and he started like laughing
uncontrollably for 30 minutes
and pal banco was telling the story how
like everybody
had to pretend to laugh with him even
though nobody had any clue what he was
laughing about
i mean he was laughing about some crazy
combination that his opponent missed
that nobody saw
yeah yeah yeah that's yasser has told me
that story like probably 10 times and
keeps forgetting that he's already told
me well amman
i think that we should do at least some
impressions
uh today but in vessel
[ __ ] as he said uh i know that tends to
make you laugh
uh yes but but i do admire your
impressions of mine
this is a huge troll nobody names their
like son
vessel [ __ ] well isn't it like bessel
but yasuo said it like vessel
yeah his name's bessel but but like you
sort of pronounce it with like a soft
you know it's like a it's like a v yeah
his name's vessel [ __ ]
yeah i thought they like speak pretty
good english i think he's belgian
or something like that so that's crazy
when that happens
but that is pretty funny and that is
really funny but in all seriousness you
were one of the inspirations for me like
starting to do impersonations so
i do owe you a debt of gratitude there
oh that's a that's a nice little uh call
out there
thanks buddy you're the og there as well
so it's credit where it's due for sure
yo thank you i uh i i think i've been
it must be uh one is it
is this fiddler one that that that you
can do i'm trying to remember there's
one accent that you can do it i just
can't even attempt it and it's it's
unreal might be a really it might be a
netflower
can you i think that's far off no
so you have a i think you have a caspar
and a nepo and both of those just like
amaze me it's a largely new amount of
practice
yes that's what this one is that you
brought this you know
as my coach looks underneath and you
knew in a corporate you know corporal
you know he
you practice someone you kind of
practice and you knew it's the master
can you do slowly
so
so you know yeah i was about i was about
to say that
in our impression time how did my guy
lose his minute back i didn't see it
past yeah it's like well he's in 20
seconds though
i got tricked i you know it was like all
impression you know haha and then
secretly dania and and one e6 here they
were teaming up against me
and suddenly they they stole their
minute back this wasn't good
thanks clara 23 months well he's got 40
seconds or this might be a time scramble
black's got the easier position though
he's got that blockade right
yep yep as long as white doesn't get
f3 in i'm i'm feeling very confident
with
that with black's position yeah if i
were white i would stand around and just
try to get that time back
because at some point black is gonna
have to try to make progress he's going
on the queen side i like that
i'm telling you this guy's a positional
wizard look at that karpovian style
boom remove double on the b file
i'm not a fan of cb5 there i would have
left the pawn on c6 because now he's
sort of backtracking on his
on his king side play he's taking too
long though he's taking two three
seconds per move
he's taking it
bishop f1 we're just in there is he
winning a piece queen g5 h4
bing bang boom okay definitely
definitely uh definitely winning a piece
but as long as we sacrificed the
play quickly it looked like a sacrifice
come on calculate take your time
calculate it
calculate no no need to calculate
calculate some variations slowly queen
takes e4 move
we know
i know him too well there we go b6 great
move no no no no no no
okay takes and he's gone e6 is hanging
queen e6 missing
miss it
very nicely done f2 maybe oh oh it's so
good the checks are being thrown in just
woven in there oh you love to see that
now come on let me ask you a question
are you familiar with the concept of a
swiss gambit
please enlighten me when you play open
tournaments
or any type of tournaments you lose the
first game as a ploy
for two reasons you make your opponent
believe
that you're not gonna win the tournament
and you're not to be reckoned with
number two
you lessen the expectations that are
then put on you
so that your opponent is the one and the
opposing team is the one that feels the
pressure
well that is indeed what we have done
here we have discussed the strategy for
many weeks prior
you know what i was about to say right
before you went in that explanation that
i'm
really feeling under a lot of pressure
right now so that that actually does
make sense
that that does make sense keep your head
up chest kid you played well
very well just a little bit i mean he
won the
he won the bishop right so he did he did
actually sort of have the
the chess position but he was he was a
little bit too slow we've had practice
here
my guys have been hanging pieces and
making up for that with time scrambles
for
you know longer than uh than most people
well a lot of a lot of experience game
two is gonna be a resounding comeback
and folks on my stream i'm gonna just
like show the scores after every game is
concluded
um otherwise i'd have no space like
those old basketball games where they
projected
the score okay
um well congratulations well played
good time management and uh we don't win
the first game very often this is
the this is actually a very scary
experience because i usually lose the
first game win the match now i've won
the first game so i'm a little nervous
actually so there's an inverse
correlation
as you explained previously between
winning the first game and winning
though yes
yes exactly i'm a little a little afraid
here that the color is going to switch
for the next game
so our lads gonna get the white pieces
fantastic shark
on your mark let's go
[Music]
50 subs yeah nice little cheer boys we
got we got game one against daniel
that's important
no you guys are good i've uh you know
i've respected the
the chess bra you know community and the
chess grind so i know you guys are good
but
we're resilient we're resilient we can
take some hits
brazilian's a good word what about when
four pawns are coming at yo face
what about b5 here iman and then
chipping away at the queen side
this guy knows his king's indian like i
know
like i know we i don't
know what i know i don't really know
anything so this but this guy knows
he's indian yeah all right you that was
convincing
that was definitely convincing well it
was a great expression have you heard of
it
okay so benoni style e6 a little bit
dubious but
this will get very sharp like e5 white
this gets very
sharp yeah i'm actually not too uh
not too worried if i'm black playing
movie six it tends to work out
at this rating level level probably more
than it doesn't like it shouldn't be a
good move but i
i think it's going to get messy enough
it is e5
trying to get into black spawn structure
i've played guild wars before in sub
battles and in uh my games against subs
he is good
but let me tell you r45 gifted thank you
so much man
but shark very tricky player now 94
though i'm very concerned
about black's position here 94 was
stronger though i think
now queen e7 holds things together what
do you think
yep yeah less we'll see how fancy he
gets
some knight d5 nonsense queen b3 is a
move d5 yeah exactly
oh 95 immediately yeah but d5 now knight
takes the fight
yeah actually he did it he did it
smarter than me he's getting a pawn for
his troubles coupons
queen a7 maybe with some c4 ideas
ish yep
yep that's definitely better try it yeah
but now this is completely lost yeah
oh you say completely lost is just uh it
honestly it's an insult
to sub battles it's a naredinski jinx
okay
as soon as i say that there tends to be
a blunder from the opposing side okay so
that was actually tactical by you
here i am thinking we're doing
commentary but no he's actually got his
own
is has some sort of nefarious intention
in mind
that's good to know i'm always gonna be
on the lookout now well white is just
vacuuming everything up though
why black might not have enough pieces
to even try with
well his knights that they're almost
both trapped in a funny way like yeah
neither of them can they're like
swimming around the depths among the
algae here queen c6
queen d6 is very clinical takes a knight
b5 maybe
some last last ditch attempts or
thanks for the sub yeah this this is
like pretty pretty good chess
from from guild wars and i'm actually
not used to it on my channel i have a
feeling that he might have snuck in here
you know maybe he's watching pogba
champs earlier like like this is the
type of talent that i'm not used to
seeing
no he's playing extremely well and he's
pouring it on here so
shark trying i like what that he's put
the bishop on d4 if he takes sunday for
at least a past pawn
in my experience that's the first step
to swindling an end game create a passed
pawn
make the opponent nervous yes he
he's got a pawn on d4 surrounded by like
tons of other pawn i love the way that
guild wars is playing but one thing i'll
say is that nice can be so deceptively
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] our 5 000 bit
drop oh my god thanks dude let's go
the bitties the bitties are coming out
that's what you need you need the
you know the back [ __ ] the comeback
[ __ ] thanks our [ __ ]
appreciate it man amazing so i'm telling
you i'm on he's got the pawn under
control
knight c4 okay get white low on time
yeah that's not even invasion happening
here
okay oh i get blunder under the exchange
okay i
i'm not she's satisfied with that
blender that might be a tactical blender
mm-hmm yep the confidence in your voice
of mine was just
so obvious you heard the voice crack did
you i heard the tiniest voice crack
but it's enough for me to know exactly
what's going the problem is when it's
still winning but d3 comes in
knight oh i'm telling you what did i
tell you about shark that guy is
impossible to bring down
okay that's a fairly decent c2 i would
say
okay d2 he wants to exceed
one that's not going to do it though can
you two there oh
ship d4 okay okay square is covered
yeah he's got to do this and then take a
well i can't really complain
this could have been worse for white
knight c3
that's worse for white
okay can i complain now you can
okay okay now now this is ridiculous
guys this is so
are you kidding me okay finally i have
the right to complain
to bring down is this mean i don't get
checkmated on h5 yeah yeah
we needed black to play h6 there we
jumped the gun with g4
h5 carving out those light squares yeah
that's that's a nice little uh
okay maybe h4 for black i i believe that
is a good proposal i'm king f5 may i
suggest yeah oh he's too close
he is uh karpovian precision right there
okay stop removing do not stalemate him
or i am going to
yeah it just doesn't make sense i see it
too often it's like 24 seconds
you should really chill chill i
completely agree like people don't have
the conception of like when supreme
karate baby freaking now i'm here hero
a reminder to people on my team it's
like guys let's not show
daniel's squad that much respect queen
rook and pawn up with 22 seconds let's
play on i mean
i think there's a reasonable chance that
that game ends in a draw
come on guys get your head in the game
all right karate baby you're the man
that's right one one
you hit your head in the game boys
that's not good for
just a second but then i remembered the
tank ready spirit
very important in these sub battles to
realize that that almost
every position that appears on screen is
winnable for both sides
it really i mean the turnarounds are
amazing i mean my heart just like
it's it's unbelievable actually so so
what's the story with your uh
board three as far as i know it this is
uh this is quite the young talent you've
got here he is and he's
credible at puzzle rush he's beating me
many times he's a tactician he's going
to
smut smell a tactic uh in edmonton from
uh city name a city from toronto okay he
he that's impressive nice geography
there and so
i believe i believe in tawny yeah i'm
really i'm
you know really well familiar with
canadian cities i know all about them
okay game boarded not sure why maybe
someone was uh
offline there for a brief sec we'll get
that on again all right
good luck danny
tian khan i've seen him in your um in
your stream
so the thing about tian khan actually is
is it's a name
from so so long ago like literally four
or five years ago when i was like doing
chess.com shows so he's in some youtube
videos on our channel
that are actually like four or five
years old it's uh it's a really old name
wow so the the ogs
exactly i'm bringing out guys to
basically
boost the spirits of the rest of the
team you know man and i
they didn't let us forget that you were
grinding five years ago by featuring you
on the cover of chess life i really like
that was a great touch
yeah there's a nice nice little nice
like uh
yeah commemoration it just you know guys
have been here for a while and yeah
this nice little [ __ ] out there oh yeah
i was impressed that they
of all the names they did not forget
yours okay so we have a london here
black's got a nice center i don't love
tawny giving up that pawn
so i'm i mean i think that
this is good for uh for kian khan for
sure
but it's also a bit of a weird uh
opening sequence he sort of just let it
happen it almost looked like
both players are happy to be here
everything right
and tiny trying to like inflect the
center 94
some tactics with knight f6 but b6 but
should be cell
i don't know i love this to be honest i
get the feeling that he's
he's like he's i guess feeling tony's
very much like a rook d1 f4 kind of guy
like yeah he just wants to explode the
position
make things go boom and well there's
none of my influence there
i feel like some people i just like
influence badly
because i do so much dubious [ __ ] and
it's like
sometimes like it's just garbage um and
i i
admit that so bishop b7 knight d6 with
knight
rookie e8 yeah i think this gets very
dicey here
and he's he's you know this is immediate
tactical stuff for him here
queen d7 black has to play but then
queen no
yeah what to do maybe
take and or sorry uh knight f5 and
rookie seven
i'm not sure if it's queen c7 h4 maybe
but then rook d8 okay he's decided to go
oh trade those queens study yes
oh my goodness but but rookie 7 is
coming in
that's so important his last tiny
changed his last name to karpov you just
don't know it
okay this is a very important move take
your time buddy
reflect on what's happening you traded
the queens what should
normally that's winded out of the sales
for attacking players
king f8 is a very strong move rookie
seven bishop c8 atani do not know rookie
set
maybe g4 slowly no
to build up you know but i don't love
this unfortunately because rook doesn't
come to e7
it shouldn't it shouldn't i have a
feeling after g4 he might go like rook
d8
and like maybe there's a rookie seven
there mm-hmm
yeah rook to jade and he does go g4 it's
a nice nice principled move there
well the issue is okay so g6 that does
create some
weaknesses i would say knight t6 here we
go
yep so now rookie six is sort of
yeah there we go wow that was in the
horizon bold primo but okay
but i agree with the oman like a lot of
people like misunderstand that 30
seconds they like prime of 50 moves
that's how stalemate happens
yeah exactly it's actually the recipe
right there but rook c7 is coming where
does that bishop go
so king g8 looks ideal maybe although
i'm not sure rook c7 is super annoying
bishop e8 has to be played in 94. yeah
1994 is what's going to hurt us here
now rook d8 here for black might be the
best way to to secure chances
yeah it's a tough one i'm telling you as
soon as it gets tactical or concrete the
man is
a [ __ ] speed demon but it's not that
clear still so this
is this is weirdly okay for black it's
weirdly okay
like you think it's great for white it
probably is good but
not you know fully decisive but a draw
in white's pocket
yeah definitely rematches on on draws so
it doesn't matter what color people are
playing
and then i think he's gonna go with them
oh my lands that was a
very weird move brook h7 is one of those
threats
maybe knight d5 in between move oh wait
d3 oh no it doesn't work okay but bishop
c4 now i
don't think he should have given that up
b3 i think was
was much more precise but now he'll win
a uh
okay oh oh f3 get the king in
get the freaking kingdom god damn oh man
he's too good he is but 30 seconds b5 b5
yeah this is oh king
okay i like the energy you got the king
in maybe an f4 check and then
yeah bishop f1 ideas for black
oh f5 let's see what he's trying to do
there's a nice little check there yeah
that'll be it
that's right tony okay take that rope
you know
could have kept that but okay
okay some stalemate ideas we're we're in
the
ballpark for stalemate mm-hmm yeah this
is where i started getting concerned
about the pre-moves
but the the great thing for you is
there's a bishop on the board had he
pre-moved g5 there he would have dropped
the queen oh
blundering the pawn but okay okay
praying for the internet now yeah it's
it's tough at this point king f8
and i don't think he's gonna get another
move in that's freaking right
it's good conversion because you should
never ever touch the bishop the bishop
is like you're you're saving grace from
stalemate what's the score again i'm
already having some amnesia i
seem to forget who's winning now after
that first game
so you forgot the first game happened so
it'd be 20.
it'd be 2o for you okay got it
that's freaking out right make sure you
keep that score in mind the entire time
and i'm gonna i'm gonna whip out my
you know uno reverse card and remind you
that i have one
extra point from the beginning right
when it matters at the end so this is
better for me i
you know the poor start here we go this
is back to chess bra
you know playbook stuff okay okay
playbook yeah well
it's a great playbook i i suggest you
lose another five or six games to really
dig yourself into a hole
we're not used to that that that's not
in the playbook i think it's at the
point where you start winning
at which which board is like the
dividing line where you i'll even tell
you i'll even tell you
so the the one where and it's not like
this is gonna be our next one but the
one where
like things are really just gonna become
uh tough for you guys to handle
it's gonna be smucker wide shaft smucker
wide chef let me let me just show myself
knucker wide shaft
1750 he's from michigan you know he's
got huge energy
and he's rated 1750 which uh for him is
definitely on the on the higher end of
you know where he wasn't from michigan i
thought we'd have a chance but
unconventional
man is a tactical dynamo so i'm looking
forward to that matchup but i'm also
looking forward to chewie
um who is basically yeah
is representing uh representing quebec
canada so this would be this would be a
big match as well big shout out to him
he's awesome
thank you so much get ready
well i'm gonna we're gonna chew on this
game i think he's gonna chew on
his opponent's position unconventional
you you you show them what you have to
say
about that okay you freaking show them
so what's that i hear in the background
what is that that was just me
fiddling with a cap of a geralt steiner
sparkling water oh i mean i got excited
i thought that i thought that was the
you know you just uncorked the beer and
that you know i will i might actually
uncork a beer i just got some guinness
which is my favorite beer so if my
chat permits me um
i might uh mine on corporate after we've
just played a couple games
okay i was gonna ask you what's the
threshold yeah you got to get another
win for you to like feel like it's
it's time to crack one open yeah yeah i
think that's okay that's good so
three's the magic number there's only a
beer on the line so over here on the
chess broad channel basically as long as
there's a game in progress
that's usually it's a weekend weekend is
my like sunday i allow myself you know
some uh some relaxing time it's been a
long week so hopefully people won't hold
it against me okay
so chewy against
your guy dashing tango intimidating yeah
yeah i always like the the bishops um
when i'm looking at the position because
i'm thinking what would i enjoy but then
i have to remember
i again nights are so tricky and and
for example here it's like suddenly
knight takes d5 blocks like just
chilling
right and it's interesting how there's
things in blitz that are
um like different from what it is in
classical like you have to factor in
like knights against bishops
you would not be afraid if you had an
hour on the clock oh whoops
and uh but you would be in like a blitz
game
yep so chewy playing black here
strong knight on d5 but white does have
the two bishops
okay keeps the bishop i like that i was
a little nervous about knight takes b4
and we would
just simply have the worst um the worst
uh
pawns ever the good thing is that the um
the isolated pawn on d4 is i think he's
gonna be familiar with territory
chewie's from quebec
they've been trying to isolate and
separate from canada for a while so
i feel like he's going to know how to
handle this you've got a very personal
um something to relate this game to
yeah you know the canadians are always
going to throw shade you know
uh we used to live in montreal as well
so we
we joined up we banded up there had a
great time
yeah well what do you call a
wait i'm trying to make a joke out of
this let me think about it okay
how would pikachu call multiple choices
multiple choice questions
or two answer type questions in canada
trudeau or false
through odor for all questions that's
good it's good
i'm definitely worried about that stream
is just losing it with left right now
now i am worried here that this beer is
not happening because look at
this attack chewie's got to play knight
e4 i think or or maybe take on c1 and go
94.
yeah 94 um
actually six that's that's a pretty
reason that's actually that's decent
because these pawns can actually be kind
of
oh oh i see something annoying yeah so
you see it too so uh at the risk of
saying it out loud knight g4 is another
option but he plays knight f7
now chewie's gotta not panic right queen
d oh no
oh no that's what we needed there no
great moves played super fast yeah that
was good good tactical vision but
i don't think black was actually in that
much trouble had he played queen 64
or queen f4 yeah yeah yep so
and this is over it's made it made on
the next move
wow that's okay it's okay yeah good
positional play by chewie but i think he
he stumbled a little bit there in the
middle game didn't play fast enough
don't you just play queen d5 here and
then try to play queen takes g2 before i
go queen f7
i think it's the best way to handle it
yeah you know you know what's gonna be
the best way to hear that when we crush
the next game that's gonna be the best
way to handle it
oh there we go i mean suddenly yeah you
know
the the stakes are back to evens here
two two
good game chewy um head head held high
we're good
we're good i can see why this might come
down to the wire though i'm on
and that's why we have our trusty 800's
our noble steeds waiting there at the
end
exactly exactly and they're capable
hands will be decided the fate of the
match
yep all right so who is it azerity gigi
and zovax are the next game
and it looks like uh your boy there gets
the white pieces
yeah poland from poland so if he's got
that russian eastern european solid
school of chess
he's gonna play a freaking buzzsaw
positional game right here
so you're calling it already positional
it's gonna be a positional game
yeah i'm calling it well the the best
thing for me to do is
call my guy an absolute tactical genius
and we're gonna see which style prevails
immovable force against unstoppable
objects
yes all right if we have our first
azerty
um if you're in chat let me know buddy
um i don't see you in the live chat so
make sure to get in so i can start the
game but
is there any gg i don't i don't have you
in in live chess unless your username
something other than what it is on the
sheet there i'm gonna violate my
principles i'm gonna crack one open i'll
be right back
okay no that's always acceptable always
acceptable you're not violating anything
in my book
nah it's sunday evening long week
i got some uh new cans of guinness i've
never seen these cans like a soda can
i like the bottles but it seemed
interesting
i even got a guinness emote so i
basically have to it's been months since
i've actually had a guinness
guinness is a very uh specific taste as
well i love it's like
it doesn't taste like any other beer
it's so smooth creamy
and i in general i like the chocolatey
kind of porters and stuff like that
so cheers folks
and here we go i'll have to get off to
get one as well we did get a win there
not that i need
criteria but uh 2-2 this is the
it's definitely off to the close start
we anticipated thanks for the thousand
bits freddie appreciate it so we have
what in english
oh but bobbinix system you gotta be
careful knight g4 already causes
problems
oh durf thanks sub okay you missed
knight g4 though that was an early
opportunity
uh knight g4 yeah yep
but now i like white's position that
pawn structure is very dynamic you know
i like it
yep some knight h4 into f5 stuff later
but you know what they say i mean double
pawns are always weaknesses uh you know
we're just gonna go ahead and believe
that over here in this game
i love that expression i really use it
all the time my chat knows how much
how much attention i pay to the pawn
structure
thank you shot jeff appreciate all the
support you guys this is awesome
okay d4 very committal move but
i i think i'm generally happy to see
that from uh
from my side of things actually on the
bottle it says best enjoyed poured into
a glass that's really okay i'm gonna get
last night
oh so you're you're not enjoying it as
much as you could
yeah they're telling me what to do
and everyone in your chat in guinness
should be poured as well i mean you're
just getting
yeah not an expert in this regard so i
defer to the wisdom
oh it was so bad out of the cam man i
couldn't drink that [ __ ]
now it's really it wasn't even guinness
it like transforms into guinness
once once you pour it okay so whites i
don't
love this d5 thing but i guess why i can
follow up with b4
he gained 30 seconds doing this the
moves were so bad i think it confused my
guy
bad so what to do now queenie one maybe
get the queen over
close position i told you it was going
to be a positional battle
yes but what you're forgetting is that
the the attack of the century is about
to be launched by black
f5 is is gonna happen quicker than you
know it knight c897 knight g6
we need to we need to make that happen
yep
bring it home we could uncork a little
tactic here i'm not sure if he's
thinking about that he's a tactical
genius as i said
right now but you know he he can be
he told me he was so g6 yeah good move
prophylaxis now knight yeah
queenie one here important to defend the
knight
it's almost like a move that might have
been played before knight h4
uh-huh is that so but i like the way he
did it he offered a tactical
motif in order to humiliate my opponent
when he missed it
mm-hmm i understand yeah now azeri
realizes in retrospect and that's going
to impact on
you know what that happens right it's so
hard to play when you realize you missed
an opportunity that's probably one of my
like psychological achilles heels in
like over the board chest
i find it so hard to focus after i okay
make a moves off
this isn't a classical game okay now
if we're if we're really uh sure what to
do here as black i think we have a great
position but it could be very difficult
to identify the right to
the right planet yeah and white has
relatively easy play i think king jutur
capture cuff one
but but it's got to be executed quickly
boom oh
what if you trap the queen wait oh my
lens that oh knight of three didn't work
between the three okay f5 was
so good is this a uh is this a phrase
that you've developed for blog champs
commentary oh my god
it's i think it's a north carolina like
expression like it's a south thing
i heard it i heard some people use it i
even heard it in like some tv show no
no yeah this is oh my god i was
distracting you
with the question wow oh okay
is he seeing the knight though e4 or f4
no no no oh yeah let's go
lucky reckon that the rook is on f2 yeah
he totally
no let's go to add insult to injury he
wins the
night oh my goodness oh man
[Music]
that that's probably the most material
that he could have lost in that amount
really i mean that yeah and now he's
gonna lose oh my god it never ends that
f-file both
damn king move the damage i gotta
respect h5
as as a principled move he's trying to
keep the g file closed which was the
only source of chaos
i gotta respect it but there's h4 and
then bishop takes h3 and then you would
have
saucer like vacuumed up the bishop of
the knight oh
that would have been filthy okay oh
voluntary
freaking team on right there rook four
was good
that's fine rookie for mate probably
i feel a meeting i think precise
technique is record further commentary
isn't that necessary
oh it's okay it's okay you
played wells off good pressure in the
middle game didn't play
precisely that f5 was very good by
zarate that was a good defense
f5 was good and as i said uh hello
tactical genius this was a beautiful
attack that you know ended up in a king
walk to h4
when check made it on the board very
beautiful attack yes that was
particularly that was really impressive
um winning with a rook and a piece extra
oh god i
could not have seen anybody else be able
to do that now this is a big match i'm
on because
you should talk to our guy
unconventional unconventional
you better have something to say about
that all right you're gonna make them
pay
three to the score right now but
everything
left to be to be decided when you say
pay you mean the
amount of 20 gifted subs um
i had a different yeah you to me that's
right well he will make them pay in the
first cents and then 20 gifts themselves
will come after that
got it got it just got it well i'm also
joining you on the on the sunday night
um uh drink here you know i've
reached the threshold that you've
outlined of three wins so uh
cheers from from my camp to yours
absolutely likewise
um a pleasure to be doing this i'm
having a lot of fun and uh
you guys are great so i think i speak
for all of us great way to spend a
sunday cheers
cheers cheers and we had 10 gifted subs
from full rook there
the username is full rook which is
pretty much what we were up in that game
are you having a guess i like it am i
having a guinness no i'm
i'm more of a liquor guy so i just got a
classic
absolutely classic remember two inches
on
but i've also opened up the shot for
wins campaign on my channel
so uh every win will be will be a shot
okay that's how i motivate my people
dude i mean like i have no other way i
had to like
get liquor involved i'm russian
you know this is how i motivate my squad
you know like
people don't understand what goes on
behind the scenes there's no bribery
none of that
it's just like hey man a couple shots
for wins let's go boys
absolutely well you won't be taking any
shots let me tell you that
so watch out next game smucker i i
informed you a while ago
i informed you about the the importance
of this match you got this show them
show them what you know
so [ __ ] wide shaft against
unconventional
spells like a reddit account created by
a 14 year old
here we go all right and
mucker is probably having a shot right
now since he's not in live chat
stealing [ __ ] herself yeah smucker
what do you have to say for yourself bud
maybe your matches smucker's jam yeah
that's hilarious reference right there
yeah i'm not too much of a liquor guy
the one liquor that i cannot even be
near
is bourbon you know everybody has their
one
if i see bourbon or i smell it i
get sick immediately like it's just it's
crazy
everyone has their one right everyone
has their one it's not tequila it's
freaking bourbon
gotcha yeah mine's mine's vodka actually
so that's
[ __ ] my blade okay yeah okay interesting
i'm not actually a huge vodka like
vodka is the only thing i think in life
that i actually can detect like fancy
versus not i wonder why that is it's not
like i have it in my genes
yeah well i think if you're at the point
that you're detecting fancy or not
then it's definitely like that's the
in-crowd for you
mm-hmm yeah but that's the only thing
i'm like that even like wine
okay like i can detect franzia or
something but but that's about it
you know i'm not like that with any
other else cars you know it doesn't
matter you know i'm i'm
a man of simple simple desires and
tastes
that's good though that's good you don't
want to be too you know over over
complicate the situation we're all going
for the same
end goal give me a nice combination of
queen sack
good energy connection and we're good
what we have
and strangely enough is the same two
bishop position that we had in
like a previous game somehow it should
be very good for white
but i just don't have that trust that
these guys know what to do with those
bishops as much as they should
mm-hmm sorry guys for opening the game
like queen g5 this is exactly what i'm
telling you the guy knows how to pose
problems to the opponents
the guy that is a tricky move the guy's
basically playing without his queen side
here
meanwhile i have to just shut up polar
bear abc 10 subs
full rook with the 10 and gear with five
subs thank you so much guys do
appreciate that a lot
well to compensate for the 20 subs that
you're going to be paying me
oh is that it i got finances now okay
get the hell rid of the knight
just know what you guys are doing
because these cells are going right back
200 well that's good i'll need to
replace the void then
um okay what's happening here i would
love to see
even just pawns sacked like f4 zach the
e3 pawn f pawn doesn't matter i'd love
to get an open line against
yeah traxxar thanks for the five gifted
man
cheers appreciate it yeah so white
definitely is better objectively ooh
there we go
queen takes sheet two now this man is
bold too that's the other thing i want
you to know about unconventional he does
not shy away
from from taking every pawn on the board
from freaking big balls chess all right
this is what this is i actually think
this is the right thing i don't think
white's got enough
though black does have to be very
careful
i would love to see the move queen d1 i
know it's not maybe the best move but
just
keep those queens on the board i swear
it will result in checkmate
right especially if black trades queens
by playing knight takes c5 queen e3 23.
i wouldn't blow this attack out out of
proportion
so you know well the thing is you know i
i just have to play queen d1
i have to play daniel stop watch the
watch this is what daniel would play
right what would daniel do what would
danny do daniel play queen you wanna
it would be like total trash but somehow
like when what would daniel do
uh how do you feel when when he makes
those comparisons and then they work
that somehow validated but i feel like
when he when he says it like usually
it's like
i i know i'm unobjective but i'm not
always like an objective i can sometimes
i can calculate
yeah you know sometimes sometimes
occasionally
but i i like it not like this guy's like
3100 blitz on the regular
like that well amanda i would like to
where are the queens i
i think i'm missing it uh where oh
yeah if you'll just give me a minute i'm
actually just going to take my headset
off i'm just looking for the queen
i am looking where is it please
a little unfortunate there because uh
right now we're in an opposite bishop
position unconventional has more pawns
but the good thing is he has more pawns
he's going to feel the pressure to win
right my guys mucker he's comfortable
with a draw and he's got to make a move
unconventional watch your clock c5 get
that [ __ ] no no he's tanking he's
panicking
oh smucker take that a4 pawn oh
unconventional blundered on e4
no damn it okay you took the right pawn
nice take it again
let's go back bishop on d5 you're good
rook f2
let's go let's play catch up on the time
yeah he's making independence smuckers
jam out of this position
he's going to he's going to destroy
white's position
can we get a bishop d4 for all the guys
in michigan cheering you on right now
thanks for the sub double the rooks he's
up on time look at that
he doesn't know what to do he's stumped
uh okay there we go a move would be nice
yep
yeah he's gonna you know he's gonna he's
gonna dispense with white's position
like you do with the um
you know the lint the flint out of the
laundry he's going to dispense with
white's position like that
the lint the lid is that what you call
that
that [ __ ] that you like empty out of
your dryer
yes but i thought you said flint yeah i
did because it flinches
i was making a joke yes i am like a
michigan joke
but isn't he from michigan no you did i
i'm like i'm like
just not you don't want stop thinking
jesus
okay that's it i told you i was gonna
rent
okay he's gotta make a move please move
guys guys this is actually a toss-up
bishop neither of these guys is
convincing myself or dania that they're
gonna win
okay but seat belts fastened seat oh no
it's 16 seconds of peace
come on buddy they're both spending too
long a month they're spending like two
seconds
way too long way too long you gotta
pre-move yeah okay
[Music]
that is how you do it that is how you do
it
absolutely beautiful your guy was so
caught up winning rook
that he completely lost the threat he
completely lost the threat
i don't care do you think i'd give it to
this couple [ __ ]
ever literally i care about a couple
rooks
guys in my eyes you freaking won
you played a fantastic middle game you
just got unlucky
we won't get unlucky again will we
smucker way to go buddy
literally putting michigan on the map
there
we go we actually do have like uh in all
seriousness one of the most random
places in a way that we have tons of
people that watch from it's just
michigan you know just it's just like
there's so many people from there
agent jl is a michigan bra as well
and this is what they got this is all
they have a guy hanging a couple rooks
and flagging this is what michigan
brings to the table
look dee ritman yo let's go more
michigan represent boys
we're only two to uh two points down we
got freaking
juggernauts on the lower boards and they
are not to be messed with
we ain't getting unlucky again now
andreas
andreas you represent australia you show
them what you got
did i not tell you i warned you about
smucker i i have to say i
didn't know it was a very well contested
game i think both deserve uh
credit but made in one and and it was
just
literally unlucky so you're good we're
gonna win this
but credit's a smucker you know he he
held on he held on
yeah we don't know what that was but he
came out on the better side of it
somehow
uh white pieces for andreas it looks
like this next game
uh scribble scrabble hopefully boys are
both in live
chess um and it seems to be
that what's happening is my side is
partying
and taking shots for all the victories
that none of them are in live chess when
i get to their
you know what i mean yeah we're
celebrating already he who laughs last
laughs longest um folks
yeah if anyone else has any you know
like google.com
gandhi quotes for daniel to live by
right now those would be great
we could find something for him i'm
gonna take a
sip of guinness because i know that
we're coming back from this
here we go all right match is on
andreas andreas e4
black's already stumped took two one too
many shots
okay so he is uh yeah he's wrapping
australia
this is this is a big week we got a we
had an australia against the world
matchup like so many players from
australia that they were like
we can take on everybody mm-hmm
unfortunately it did not go as planned
for the aussies but i i got a lot of
respect for
the australian chess uh you're about to
have more spectrum when they kick
your guys's ass now scribble scrabble
what do you know about him
gribble scrabble drew scribbly recently
like he's sort of been dwelling at a
reading level for a while and then all
of a sudden we hosted like an arena
the guy won like a 100 points in the
arena hit a new high rating
and he's just been mr big talk since
then he's like you know i can clap
anyone like
you know all of a sudden he's like he's
the [ __ ] so
so honestly he's kind of on a high horse
right now and this would be more
ammunition for the ego if he was to win
this right here well he's already lost
the funnel though
to be fair he does have that
compensation of of the bishop oh my god
you better take this truck i can't watch
this
he's not gonna just tell me if he's okay
no but he's not
we all know he's not taking the ropes
yes let's go
that's what i'm talking about
unbelievable it's like that ago modern
video exactly where he where the guy
didn't take the rook
do not trust these guys come on but he's
still up a point
that is just a classic example uh
textbook australian joke
ah amanda you're forgetting though
andreas is up upon still and he's
clearly a very good positional player
okay if he trusted his opponent he won't
trust him again okay i think he realizes
that now he's going to put a knight on
d5 he's going to win
you got this right he doesn't need to
take
hanging piece right he doesn't need to
exploit a blunder he wants to just show
his superiority in chess
is understanding right right
so when he starts to do that just give
me a heads up
with that being said you don't take that
goddamn hanging rook next time and you
and
you're gonna you're gonna live to regret
it
i have to get that out it's bishop e3
okay
are we gonna see knight d5 well he's got
to do it otherwise bishop e3 could be
very
yep wow of course of course of course he
sees it
as i like i don't know that's always my
pre-tilt
expression um no no i know it's so well
like i've heard it i was i was
even gonna like i have that saved for
like a rainy day of like i need to roast
dania like that that's my i have that
phrase in storage
my friends here were roasting the hell
out of me yesterday and uh
if there's like a couple of expressions
i always go through when i'm
when i'm like in pre-tilts or tilting
first the first is of course you see
the second is i use the word precise
like
oh he of course he's so precise like
yeah of course yeah i say of course like
i say the words of course
to start every sentence yeah of course
yeah he's like so good
yeah of course he's the best player in
the world right he's basically a guy of
course he's like
playing so well against in this match
like
yeah and then i start like lifting my
mouse and then putting it back on the
desk which is
where i wish i knew mine like do you
know any of mine i'm trying to think
you're very level-headed fairly
level-headed i
i internalize a lot of the tilt yeah
maybe some of my chats
can help me out well when i was like
getting better and
from tilting all the time i was you know
i looked up to you as one of the one of
the people who
you know and i know it's like you're a
person you you experience those emotions
but but you can
rethink things and you can you know you
can be more positive that actually helps
your chest
oh what happened whoa what the hell
happened
what would you say i was not even
picking he blunted a [ __ ] with a rook
that's right why did i tell you about
andreas rook 81 like
look at that move queen takes you five
or sixty four i didn't even
notice this amazing okay you saved
you're saved you're good you i'm not
banning you for my stream andreas now
just win oh this goodness
oh who believes he's got more he's got a
lot of time bishop e7 who believes three
both look like good moves
bishop b3 don't blunder that pawn
andreas
yeah very solid solid karpovian aussie
style outback steakhouse freaking grill
black's position like a sirloin steak
queen a3 so i would say that i
i agree i'm i think i'm pretty
level-headed um
a lot of internalization but one of the
things that i think i go to
is that i think i say that that that's
very disturbing something's very
that's very disturbing that it's
interesting very disturbing
like a bad move by me or a good move by
him it qualifies the same that's very
disturbing
mm-hmm and that's the start that's when
the ball starts rolling down
right it's everybody has has their
phrase that they say
and repeat i like a mantra
yep yep nice pun there as well
wait wait yeah the thing is that the
thing about me which is very simple it's
just
i don't say anything oh rooksy won i
mean dude you think that's me
if that's gonna work anyway don't give
me a hurt i mean
okay oh my god
that's how we get once he's done credit
wouldn't you say this is kind of like a
poker thing like shouldn't you
if you play queen d4 and you realize the
blender shouldn't you just play rook c1
you've got six seconds left
like you may as well just throw it there
just in case you're getting scarier
opponent yeah
yeah and plays rook t1 here right yeah
49. exactly that's totally exactly
that's pretty disturbing i'm on
[Music]
you